hello again  sorry i'm late mr amnesty  not late at all  [Music]  let's fight ahead  we're proud of our work  presence in this facility  while technically a punishment is a  privilege  where have you been drug study  in science we have to explore the  unknown  living testimony up and down a lot  weirder stuff than usual this is new  frontier stuff here  before we begin i need your permission  to administer your name for me  this place can really mess with your  head  drip on acknowledge drip on acknowledge  acknowledge  it  let's do this  [Music]  this doesn't feel right  time to worry about crossing lines was a  lot of lines ago  our work will save lives  not just one life many lives  [Music]  we're making the world a better place  you want is redemption  and this is how you're gonna find it  we're selling peace in the harmony  itself  beautiful people get away with too much  and i say that having benefited myself  from time to time  [Music]  [Music]  you